los ocho presidentes en 20 años la
muestra de una convulsa realidad
política en perú
[Música]
en noviembre de 2002 eventos casi
paralelos ocurrían en tokio y en lima a
la vez siento mucho
esta renuncia
causado
tanta incertidumbre
construcción
e incluso indignación
mientras el entonces presidente alberto
fujimori se anunciaba el congreso lo
destituía argumentando actos de
corrupción e incapacidad moral
permanente
[Aplausos]
[Música]
por brote y por la tras la salida de
fujimori el presidente del congreso
valentín paniagua asumió de manera
interina como mandatario unos meses
después el opositor alejandro toledo
ganó las elecciones
pero la estabilidad no llegó durante su
mandato el país quedó paralizado por
semanas de huelgas en diciembre de 2003
toledo exigió la renuncia de todos sus
ministros para desactivar un escándalo
de tráfico de influencias que
involucraba a su primera ministra
beatriz merino que no avanzaremos sino
iniciamos un punto de quiebre al
interior del gobierno
[Aplausos]
a toledo lo sucedería un viejo conocido
de la política peruana en julio de 2006
volvía al poder el ex presidente alan
garcía tras dos años al mando su
gabinete tuvo que renunciar para impedir
la aprobación de un nuevo voto de
censura en el congreso por recibir pagos
a cambio de concesiones a la compañía
noruega discover petroleum
en junio de 2011 el militar retirado de
izquierda ollanta humala ganó por un
estrecho margen a la hija del ex
presidente alberto fujimori keiko se
convirtió así en el primer gobernante
izquierdista en perú en 36 años
que suscribo la patria que ejerceré
fielmente en 2016
keiko fujimori perdió de nuevo unas
elecciones presidenciales esta vez ante
el ex banquero de woolwich pedro pablo
kuczynski
pese la derrota su partido consiguió una
amplia mayoría en el congreso iniciando
así una guerra entre el ejecutivo y el
legislativo que terminó con la renuncia
de kuczynski y la llegada de martín
vizcarra tras la revelación de unos
audios en los que se evidencian posibles
acuerdos entre kuczynski y los
congresistas fujimoristas para indultar
al ex presidente alberto fujimori a
cambio de no ser destituido
[Aplausos]
2019 sería un año de tragedias y
escándalos en abril el ex presidente
alan garcía se suicidó cuando iba a ser
arrestado en la investigación de los
sobornos de la compañía o de 'break'
en septiembre vizcarra disolvió el
congreso en octubre keiko fujimori fue
enviada a prisión preventiva mientras
que 2020 sería el año de los juicios
políticos en septiembre el congreso
aprobó una moción de censura para
destituir a vizcarra por presuntos
contratos irregulares con un cantante no
me corro
no lo he hecho antes y no lo voy a hacer
ahora
pero poco después de salir airosos
comenzó el proceso en noviembre donde
finalmente se aprobó su destitución